and so I'm all about creating those  experiences where it's like wow that was  incredible and I and I'm not at creating  anything at the same time it's more of  this idea of putting together the  perfect location with the perfect food  with the perfect like you know medicine  and group of facilitators that are going  to really bring people through a deep  transformational experience that starts  with the preparation all the way through  the end with the integration usually  working with five Meo DMT as well as  iboga but both separately so those are  two different retreat formats like for  instance with the five amel retreat we  we do purification rituals to prepare  the person to go into this deep work  with the bufo alvarius and that includes  doing two miscall so sweat lodge  traditional sweat lodge to really help  them you know kind of cleanse some  layers off to allow them to surrender  deeper into the work